And I would say that one of the things that drives the collectivist ethos,
which is often formulated in terms of compassion for the oppressed,
which is something we'll talk about a little bit later,
is actually a deep desire to at all costs,
avoid that responsibility.
And it's no wonder because the responsibility is overwhelming.
Say The world fundamentally is a tragic place,
right?
It's a place in which each of us is broken and it's contaminated by the ever
present reality of betrayal and malevolence and to shoulder the responsibility
first for even admitting to that.
And second for assuming that you are duty bound,
let's say,
to do something about that.
Well,
that's a task that anyone who has his or her eyes open should be leery of
accepting.
And I would say,
well,
perhaps there's no credible reason for accepting it except that every other
alternative is worse.
Okay?
And so that's a brutal fact.
So the antidote to collectivism is individualism,
but it's not the individualism of the privileged person with rights.
It's the terrible burden of the individual who determines that he or she will
shoulder their responsibility to that most.
So I developed that idea in maps of meaning
that,
and I made a lot of lectures about that book,
many of which are on Youtube,
some of which have become widely viewed,
I would say by a hundreds of thousands of people now.
And so that and that course always had a dramatic effect on my students and
their most typical comment.
There's two classes of typical comments.
Okay.
That I got from students about my maps of meaning courses,
isn't it?
It's the same comments that I get from people now when they come and talk to me
about my lectures.
The first comment is,
and this is about maybe a quarter of the people,
is that
watching the lectures are taking the course,
enabled them to put words to things they knew,
they knew but didn't know how to say.
And so,
and that's fine because that was an ex that was actually an explicit purpose of
the writing and the course.
And the second is that it helped people straightened out their lives.
And that's also not that surprising to me because a lot of what I integrated
into that book and the lectures and then the lectures were also associated with
my personality course were ideas from the great clinical psychologists and
psychiatrists of the 20th century.
It was a dozen of them or so,
or maybe 20 who were all outstanding geniuses,
have slightly different types who learned all sorts of things about how people
could put them self together properly as individuals.
And if you learn about those things,
they're actually really helpful.
That's not surprising because they sit at the core of an entire domain of
science and art,
let's say,
devoted to improving people's individual lives.
I wove the responsibility idea into 12 rules cause that's really what it is.
In some sense.
It's a call to the voluntary adoption of maximal individual responsibility and
it's a psychological work,
not a political work.
Now I think the reason that it's attracted so much political attention,
let's say some of which gun lager referred to in the introduction is,
well,
there's two reasons.
One is because I took what might be regarded as a political stance about some
compelled speech legislation in Canada.
I never regarded that as a political move because I regarded the legislation
itself as something that wasn't a political move.
I regarded it as an attempt by the politicians to jump outside their domain of
acceptable conduct into the philosophical or even the theological realm because
you don't mess with the idea of free speech in a Western country.
And there's very sophisticated reasons for that.
And it doesn't matter what your reasons for doing it are.
You don't go there.
And so,
but it happened to be the more radical leftists that were pushing this forward.
And because I objected to it,
then it was in their interest to assume that I must be the worst sort of right
wing.
Um,
die hard I suppose,
because otherwise they'd have to contend with my actual arguments.
And so it's simpler just to shoot the messenger than to contend with the
arguments.
And you know,
if you stand up and say there's something wrong in a place like Canada where
most things aren't wrong,
then it's reasonable also for people to assume there must be something wrong
with you because most of the time there isn't anything wrong with the country
and so a certain amount of testing is a reasonable thing for people to do.
I guess the other element of this that's political in some sense though,
is that within the collectivist viewpoint,
this is something that's very interesting with regard to free speech.
I didn't really figure this out until a couple of weeks ago.
Although the radical leftists,
and you see this particularly in the United States now,
although the Americans have a very strong tradition of free speech,
the radical leftists are opposed to freedom of speech,
but that's not really right.
It's not the way to think about it.
In the radical leftist collectivist view of the world,
there's actually no such thing as free speech.
It said worst then,
then opposing it because the collectivists believe that you're nothing but an
Avatar of your group.
First of all,
there is no you.
You're defined by your group membership.
And then the world is a landscape of groups each vying for predominance.
And that's what there is.
And it's,
and so when you say that you're speaking your mind,
that isn't something that you can do from the collectivist viewpoint.
What you're doing is acting as an unconscious Avatar of the power demands of
your group.
There's no you,
there was no free speech.
There's no your opinion.
There's no facts for that matter.
Everything is to be viewed in relationship to the power struggle between groups
that even in principle cannot communicate.
And so the other reason that I detest,
let's say the collectivist viewpoint is because I see that it leads nowhere but
to conflict.
Because if people cannot speak as individuals between groups,
then all they can do is submit or fight.
Those are the options,
right?
Negotiation,
capitulation or warfare.
Those are the options.
And the only
process that allows for negotiation in the absence of capitulation or conflict
is speech.
Because we can talk over our differences and that discussion is going to be
contentious because we actually have differences.
But compared to the contentiousness of not talking over the differences,
it's a walk in the park.
You know,
I saw something quite remarkable that when I was in London a month and a half
ago,
I was on this political show and one of the things they did in this section that
didn't have anything to do with me was to show a bunch of clips from the,
the,
there's a question period that the British have evolved where the opposition can
go after the prime minister.
And the woman that was appearing with me on the show had written a book about
that called Punch and Judy,
if I remember correctly,
and they showed a bunch of clips of English mps attacking the prime minister and
the prime minister's response all the way from Thatcher forward.
It was absolutely vicious in the way that,
well educated British people can be vicious,
which is very impressive form of viciousness.
Um,
Eh,
it was no holds barred verbal combat.
And you might think,
well,
isn't that horrible?
Because it's certainly rife,
let's say with micro aggressions,
but it's not horrible because none of them had their hands around each other's
necks,
right?
It was all civilized.
It was everyone was standing where they were supposed to stand and they were
hurling invective and making criticisms and making accusations and defending
themselves and all of that.
But it was all contained within the peaceful confines of this,
of the house of parliament.
And that's our miracle,
really.
It's a miracle.
And the British are particularly good at that.
And so you leave free speech alone because the alternative to free speeches,
capitulation or conflict,
and unless you want one of those or both,
and you might,
then you don't interfere with the mechanism that enables people's people to
state the nature of their reality and to clarify that and to negotiate with
others,
even though that negotiation is painful and emotionally demanding and
threatening and anxiety provoking and aggression instigating and all of those
things,
because the alternative is far worse.